it all starts with the switching of
lopez
it puts too much pressure on your
defense paul deflects it
crowded and bridges bridges up inside
blocked by attenua
what a recovery when the bucks come the
other way
holiday spins layup shot will go and
lopez is fouled
for a guy with a hyper extended knee
what a fantastic defensive play
this is reminiscent of lebron james
in cleveland against golden state what
an effort
[Applause]
incredible block
[Applause]
he only knows one way to play just
perfect timing
get too complicated
[Applause]
now booker with tucker on him throws it
up for ayton
shot blocked by a compound
sensational block shot this is one of
the great recovery plays
you'll ever see the log booker
to ayton we've seen it many times and
that reaction
and block is special multiple effort
on the play stops the penetration of
booker doesn't give up
turns elevates blocks the layup attempt
that's big time
by young what a series
here in this 2021 nba finals here in
game four the bucks win it 109